[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hey, there.
Why so gloomy?
ANDROID: The Android
Summit is over.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Ah.
ANDROID: It was a great event.
So many developers
building cool stuff.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
ANDROID: And Dave
Burke presented.
That was great.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
I know he's very special to you.
But you know what?
ANDROID: No, what?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
You should cheer up,
because a new version
of Google Play Services
has just been released.
ANDROID: That's great.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yay.
ANDROID: Yee-haw.
Woo-hoo.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Woo.
ANDROID: Woo-hoo-hoo.
Yeah.
Awesome.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
For you developers,
this means it's time to go out
there and build better apps
using Google Play Services.
Let's check out the highlights.
Welcome to release 8.4
of Google Play Services.
Let's start this off
with new announcements
for the App Invites API.
As you may recall, you can
already add your own custom
image that your
friends will see when
they receive an app invite.
Well, in this release, we took
that concept even further now
allowing you to put any custom
content for the entire invite.
This gives you the power to
truly customize the invite
to perfectly match your
context and make the invite as
attractive as possible.
And now turning to the Maps API.
As you know, it's been
possible to draw polygons
on maps for a long time.
For example, here we have a map
of Mountain View in California,
and here we have drawn a polygon
around the Moffett Airfield.
And here's a polygon
around my favorite working
place, the Googleplex.
The cool thing we
introduced in this release
is that you can add a Click
Listener to these polygons.
So for example, if
the user clicked
on the polygon around
Googleplex, then
your app could
automatically zoom
into the entire area you have
defined for that polygon.
So this brings user
interactions to the next level.
Turning our attention to the
Play Games Player Stats API.
Remember that in
a previous release
we talked about
how important data
is to understand
game player behavior,
and that the Player Stats
API in Play Game Services
puts structure to
it, allowing you
to turn this data
into actions based
on user spending, engagement,
and progression in your game.
Well, in this release
we've extended this concept
by allowing you to look into
the future, because we're now
giving you two probabilities you
can take actions based on-- how
likely your users are to churn
and how likely your users are
to spend money
over the next week.
And this is almost
like magic since it's
giving you a hint of what
might happen in the future.
Prior to this release, it
could have looked something
like this.
[DREAM SEQUENCE MUSIC]
[THUNDER]
WIZARD: OK, let's
predict this app.
No.
Churn prediction.
OK, let's predict another app.
[THUNDER]
Yes.
[CASH REGISTER DINGING]
Revenue prediction.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Phew.
Luckily that was
how it could have
looked like before this release
of Google Play Services.
Now both of these probabilities
are part of Player Stats API,
giving you the
power to understand
player behavior at a
level previously only
available to big studios.
And we also have
some announcements
for Fused Location Provider.
As you know, Fused
Location Provider
can combine
information using GPS,
cell tower, and Wi-Fi signals to
accurately determine position.
In this release, we
have greatly improved
how Fused Location
Provider detects location
from cell towers.
Before, location was retrieved
using only the primary cell
tower.
But now, Fused Location Provider
also uses other towers nearby
to provide accurate location.
And we've also improved location
detection from Wi-Fi access
points, particularly in areas
where GPS is not available,
such as indoors.
And you get even more
with this release,
because we have also
important announcements
for the Nearby API.
Remember the Nearby Publish
Subscribe Architecture
which allows your app to detect
and retrieve data from beacons?
Well, in this release we've
enhanced this capability
so your app does not have
to be in the foreground
to detect a beacon.
You can now get notified
when a beacon is nearby,
even when your app
is in the background.
Check out the release blog
post for more information.
And for the Mobile
Vision API, we now
have added support
for Aztec Bar Codes.
And that's it for the
highlights of this release,
but check out some of these
other resources as well.
Now it's your turn
to build better apps
using Google Play Services.
So go out there and
create some great apps.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.
[EXPLOSION]
WIZARD: Yes.
Yes.
[HAMSTER SQUEAKING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
WIZARD: Revenue prediction.